[Music]
you're watching the press preview it's
our first look at sunday's front pages
and in the next 20 minutes or so we'll
see what's making the headlines tonight
with journalist and author christina
patterson and the leader writer at the
daily telegraph tim stanley speaking to
them in a moment first of all let's
check out those front pages for you
we'll start with the observer leading
with the rapidly escalating taliban
takeover in afghanistan as citizens flee
the capital kabul before the militants
arrive
the express focuses on the aftermath of
the plymouth shootings with one legal
expert telling the paper that jake
davison's actions should be treated as a
terrorist attack despite police ruling
that out
well the telegraph also looks at the
situation in plymouth those awful
killings quoting a former metropolitan
police chief who's called for police to
monitor social media accounts of those
applying for firearms licenses
sunday times leading an investigation
into the international spread of the
kovid 19 pandemic at the beginning of
2020 with the headline china the who and
the power grab that fuel the pandemic
while the star brings us claims from a
so-called egghead that boozing is in
fact good for you especially if you're
not very attractive and looking for
romance
and i'm joined tonight by journalist and
author christina patterson and leader
writer at the daily telegraph tim
stanley great to see you uh this evening
thanks for joining us and let's start
christina shall we with the front of the
observer uh events
moving very quickly aren't they in
afghanistan and not in a good direction
uh afghans flee kabul in panic because
we know now the taliban is getting
closer by the hour i mean they're saying
now it's just uh seven miles from the
capital and it all goes to
show that things really have taken so
many people by surprise and joe biden in
the last hour announcing that he's
sending another 2 000 troops initially
it was 3 000. now he's sending 5 000 um
clearly he believes the situation is
incredibly serious now
well he knows i mean anyone could have
told him the situation was going to be
incredibly serious but he clearly didn't
think it was serious enough to warrant
keeping troops in afghanistan and i have
to say i think this is a terrible
terrible
failure moral fear of the west but in
particular
they launched this war on afghanistan
because of the 9 11
events and obviously those were tragic
in american history the evidence as we
know for attacking afghanistan was
extremely slender and it appears to
achieve tragically absolutely nothing
but in the 20 years since then girls in
afghanistan women in afghanistan have
been able to have something more like a
normal life they have had education they
have not been under the horrific
oppressive regime that the taliban have
imposed on afghanistan for so long they
will lose all of that now and the world
will watch not only a country that will
probably be in a civil war pretty
swiftly well actually already is but in
which people have had their futures
snatched from them it's not just a case
of bloodshed there will be bloodshed but
this is a country that will go right
back to
the terrible state it was in before and
i think
this is a tragedy
it's a terrible terrible failure and it
also means that british and american
troops died in vain i know boris johnson
said they didn't but that is a lie they
died in vain they died for absolutely
nothing and it's a terrible thing for
their family to hear but it is the truth
of it so heartbreaking situation
yeah i mean be good to get your thoughts
on this uh tim um clearly as christina
was saying afghans will feel terribly
let down by the us but they'll also be
feeling let down by their own
politicians and their own military as
well i mean the resistance has collapsed
hasn't it
the number was quoted that there were
300 000 fighters on the side of the
afghan state but they seem to have just
disappeared it just faded away
and if you like that
is
the most damning verdict on the project
of the last 20 years
if as soon as the west left
the state that we have been patiently
trying to construct collapsed
then clearly the project was not working
uh it is indeed it is indeed a tragedy
but the two practical questions for
those who are saying it's a tragedy and
something must be done the two practical
questions are
at this stage what
because you're right joe biden is
putting in more troops although that is
he says simply in order to achieve a
more orderly drawdown but if the west
were to suddenly reverse positions
overnight put in more troops and support
the afghan government that would put
them in a shooting war with the taliban
all over again so that's question one
what in the short term do you do
if you want to stop the advance of the
taliban
that doesn't mean we end up in an
all-out war with them
the second question is when does the
mission end
and what does victory in this mission
look like how long are we supposed to
stay in afghanistan until it's ready for
us to leave and the events the last few
days after two decades imply that would
be a very very long time indeed and
ultimately the american taxpayer
ran out of patience
and they voted yeah i mean it's an
interesting point
between two men promising to end the war
in afghanistan
and to some surprise it wasn't trump who
ended up doing it it was joe biden yeah
it's a very interesting point that tim
and let's just finish this segment uh
christina or on on it i mean that didn't
feel to me that there was a huge
clamoring in the u.s to bring troops
home and and let's not forget that uh
british troops were in germany weren't
they for 40 years uh the u.s has had
troops in in south korea and japan for
for longer than that even did they have
to come home was there a sense that um
20 years is long enough
well i think
i don't i don't think there was a huge
camera from the public that it looks as
though
there's no great objection for she was
being withdrawn and there wouldn't be
because who wouldn't want to see their
troops back home and i'm sure american
taxpayers like british taxpayers don't
particularly want to have to pay for
long-term troops for me that's not the
point the point is that if you
and we you know we should have
discovered this by now if you decide to
solve problems like terrorism by
invading other countries then you have
to take responsibility for the actions
you take and you can then dream up all
kinds of noble
rationales for what you were doing and
the ostensible rationale was meant to be
about saving the west from radicalism
and uh that appeared to have very little
to do with what actually happened but if
what what we did try to sort of do was
civilize afghanistan get rid of the
taliban put them into retreat and to do
that and then withdraw seems to me an
utter waste of time and a terrible
moral abnegation because it gives people
a taste of something they can't
otherwise have i mean on those grounds
you might as well march into north korea
and say they're having a terrible time
let's go and sort them out it's just
i don't know i mean it was all strutting
around on a world stage wasn't it and as
we know uh tony blair you know was keen
to be uh close to george bush and uh we
had to be
um
you know the kind of
favored ones always who were close to
the us having to prove our special
relationship and we did that by
sacrificing lives to no end whatsoever
so i think it's an absolute tragedy okay
all right well listen i want to move on
because
we're heading to the break and let's
look at the front of the sunday express
which is focusing on those awful events
this week in plymouth killing spree a
terror
attack um
there's been a lot of debate tim hasn't
there about whether it was terrorism or
whether it wasn't what are your thoughts
the big debates are going to be one what
you do to prevent this sort of thing and
there's a story on the front cover of
the telegraph about the suggesting that
the police should troll through people's
social media accounts before granting
them a fire firearms license to see if
they are spewing hate online that should
affect decisions about firearms but the
other debate as you say is is what
should we call
what happened was this terrorism the
police are sometimes cautious about
calling things terrorism and i i share
that caution because there's a fine line
between um there's fine time between
criminalism criminality
uh mental sickness
and terrorism
on the other hand there is also the risk
of a double standard that whenever there
is a violent crime which is carried out
by someone with links to islamism there
is an immediate rush to call it a terror
incident
whereas sometimes when it's someone who
is in this case uh straight white
christian inverted commas male
who does something terrible like this
kills lots of people essentially for a
sort of political psychological motive
there's more caution about calling it
terrorism and perhaps there shouldn't be
i might my sense is that somewhere on
the line that the definition of what is
terrorism has become blurred but
undoubtedly what this man did was
externalize his internal anger it seems
uh he was
if not done to do it there was a sort of
an intellectual framework behind it a
community of people of like minds
encouraging his psychopathy
so it's it's it's difficult not to class
out as terrorists yeah so i wouldn't be
surprised if we have in the last few
days very tragically discovered a whole
new form of terrorism yeah okay um
christine we've got less than a minute
but um
we'll look at from the sunday telegraph
forced gun owners to face online hate
trawlers tim was was saying there i mean
is that sensible do you think i mean you
know employers look at people's social
media before they offer people jobs
shouldn't we be doing the same with with
gun licenses
i think we should i mean obviously it's
a tragedy that he was given a gun
license it's also utterly
incomprehensible anyone who had looked
at his mental health history would have
realized that wasn't a good idea but i
absolutely agree i think if you apply
for a job and you have your social media
scrutinized and you do now you certainly
should if you get a gun i mean the one
thing i would say that is vaguely
positive in these terrible circumstances
is that we don't have these things every
day which they do in the u.s i mean this
stuff happens all the time in the u.s
and there was the uh i recently reviewed
a fact last weekend a book of essays for
sunday times about um which is called
the right to sex and the trigger for
that uh was um the uh guy elliott
cunningham surname now but in in 2014
2015
who launched um a killing spree
and you know became the world's most
famous incel so-called
i'm i'm kind of
cautious about calling these terrorist
incidents i think the terrorist element
is to do with the social media
mobilization and the labels um but there
have always been disturbed people who
have been bitter and angry about their
personal situations and i i think if you
do call that terrorism i'm not sure how
helpful that is but i do think what is
unnecessary is looking at is looking at
those communities as online communities
yeah okay interesting point we must
leave it there thank you both for the
moment coming up former ministers could
be forced to pay up if they're found to
break lobbying rules that's on the front
of tomorrow's sunday telegraph
discussing that and more in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
hello again christina and tim still with
us tim let's turn to the sunday
telegraph ministers to lose cash under
lobbying curbs tell us more
this is in the wake of the greenville
lobbying saga whereby david cameron was
accused
of lobbying friends in the government on
behalf of the green cell finance company
which subsequently went under one should
add that david cameron was found not
guilty of breaking rules
but others have said that that just
though the rules aren't tough enough or
at least clear enough more are not more
not effectively policed enough
the government is weighing up changes to
the rules uh to say that for instance
instead of just being banned from
lobbying after being a minister for two
years that you should be banned for five
years tightening up the rules on civil
service links to private business but
also as you mentioned
they want to introduce the idea that if
you are found to be breaking the rules
you face a financial penalty when
ministers step down or are sacked
they can receive quite a substantial
payout i think it's up to 16 000 pounds
and the proposal is that if you are
caught breaking the ministerial code
some of that money should be clawed back
and returned to the taxpayer
interesting you can read more about that
in the sunday telegraph and christina
let's finish with this front page of the
sunday times
a big investigation by the insight team
uh china the who and the power grab that
fuel the pandemic
yes well i must say the sunday times
insight team have done really really
fantastic work throughout the whole
pandemic they were the ones who
initially uncovered the fact that uh
boris johnson had missed five cobra
meetings
last march at the very start of the
pandemic but this is about essentially
how china took over the who or rather
influenced the who after the
um
mayor's
near pandemic but it wasn't a pandemic
thank goodness
and it is shocking i mean a lot of this
has emerged already we did know that
china had had its uh heavy influence
with the who but the degree of the
influence
is really really worrying and four
million people have died through this
pandemic many more will die
before it is over
and if the wh it looks as if if the who
had not been unduly influenced by china
at the start and followed lines that
china seems to have forced it to have
taken then many many of those deaths
could have been prevented so
very sad story and very worrying and it
just shows how china's influence both
over the who but particularly in africa
and through
um
policies like the belton road you know
it is just growing its influence in
really frightening ways yeah interesting
stuff okay for now christina tim thank
you very much